the broader question is is Donald Trump
more generally being played or
manipulated or compromised by Russia two
former intelligence chiefs believe so
former Chiefs of American intelligence
agencies as well as Republican Senator
John McCain believe that donald trump is
putting the America the American people
and the United States itself in danger
in fact peril was the word that they
used former Director of National
Intelligence James clapper and former
CIA director John Brennan responded to
Donald Trump recently calling them
political hacks as I told you about
earlier on today's program because they
believe their own intelligence
effectively we have a quote from John
Brennan the former CIA director who said
it demonstrates to mr. Putin that Donald
Trump can be played by foreign leaders
who were going to appeal to his ego and
try to play upon his insecurities which
is a very very worrisome from a national
security standpoint former DNI James
clapper perfectly building on this ego
element of what's going on James clapper
saying I think he meaning Trump seems
very susceptible to rolling out the red
carpet honor guards and all the
trappings and pomp and circumstance that
come with the office I think that
appeals to him and it plays to his
insecurities yes I do think that both
the Chinese and the Russians can play
him and Republican Senator John McCain
also Bigley disturbed by Trump's recent
comments saying quote President Trump
today stated that he believed Latimer
Putin is being sincere when he denies
Russian interference in the 2016
presidential election and reiterated
that he hopes to cooperate with Russia
and Syria
there's nothing America first about
taking the word of a KGB Colonel over
that of the American intelligence
community Vladimir Putin does not have
America's interest at heart to believe
otherwise is not only naive but also
places our national security at risk the
reaction from the right ideally would be
wait wait hold on a second serious
respected intelligence officials who
work to keep us safe for years and years
top officials are saying this maybe we
should listen nope they're just
political hacks wait wait wait our
respected
Republican senator who is not known for
hyperbole who is not known for extremism
in his beliefs not a guy I agree with on
many issues but not known as a
hyperbolic guy John McCain he's
concerned about what he sees maybe we
should listen now he's off his meds he's
a crazy old man
or even worse things about his brain
cancer the big picture
is that Trump respects those who respect
him full-stop Trump panders to those who
he sees as pandering to him any
reasonably intelligent person and Putin
is one for sure right knows by now
exactly how to manipulate Donald Trump
and Trump's ego his inability to have
real friendships his entire personality
complex makes him very manipulative that
there is no doubt whatsoever that
Vladimir Putin is an expert in and
that's how you get Trump and others
falling for this but why would it be bad
to have better relations with other
countries that's all that's going on
that's one of those statements that in a
literal sense isn't wrong look yeah it's
generally better to have relationships
with other countries but it misses the
disturbing reality of why Trump thinks
that that's what he's working towards
with Vladimir Putin and the scariest
part of all this is that Trump may be
the victim in Trump Russia collusion
rather than the perpetrator which
wouldn't make it any less dangerous for
American national security will we ever
find out the truth I don't know
hopefully I know that I'm still sort of
naively holding out hope that we'll get
the full story at some point from Robert
Muller we will see